[Música]
ah
a finales de 2019 medicina legal dijo
que en colombia faltan alrededor de 200
mil cuerpos por exhumar e identificar
una cifra que solo en cementerios de
colombia cuenta con más de 30 mil
cuerpos identificados pero no reclamados
el acuerdo de paz de 2016 con la
guerrilla de las farc vio nacer la gp la
jurisdicción especial para la paz que
busca la verdad y la reparación esta
semana fueron entregados cuatro cuerpos
en el municipio de dabeiba de los cuales
dos eran niños que desaparecieron en
1997 durante una incursión paramilitar
en el municipio en dabeiba se cree que
hay seiscientas desapariciones forzadas
mientras que la jefe ya habría exhumado
los restos de 54 personas son muchos los
capítulos de desapariciones forzadas en
colombia los cuales han sido perpetrados
por distintos agentes armados por
ejemplo uno de los más emblemáticos la
toma de palacio de justicia en bogotá
por parte de la guerrilla del m-19 este
mes de noviembre cumplió 35 años en ese
suceso tras un operativo militar
murieron 98 personas y 11 continúan hoy
desaparecidas después de haber sido
rescatadas del palacio un conflicto
permanente en colombia en el qué
miles de familias continúan buscando a
sus seres queridos
[Música]
la desaparición forzada es una práctica
que se llevó a cabo de manera
sistemática en méxico en la década de
1960 en 1970 como una política del
estado para erradicar la disidencia sin
embargo en la actualidad de acuerdo con
el subsecretario de gobernación
alejandro oficinas dada la
descomposición social esa problemática
se ha asociado al crimen organizado y la
corrupción gubernamental dijo que de
2006 a la fecha se tiene un registro
histórico de 77 mil desaparecidos y 2019
ha sido el año con un mayor número de
reportes no se tiene la cifra de 8 mil
300 desaparecidos asimismo se han
descubierto más de 4.000 fosas
clandestinas de las que se ha exhumado a
más de 6 mil cuerpos veracruz y
tamaulipas son los estados con mayor
presencia de este fenómeno por otra
parte el presidente de lópez obrador
firmó la aceptación para que el comité
de naciones unidas contra la
desaparición forzada pueda recibir e
investigar denuncias
2010 una medida que se tuvo congelada
por más de una década
[Música]
según el comité de familiares de
detenidos y desaparecidos en honduras
unos 18 hondureños han desaparecido en
lo que va del año de acuerdo a la
presidenta de europa de berta oliva
hasta 18 desapariciones se han dado
durante la época de confinamiento donde
se han suspendido garantías
constitucionales se han implementado
toques de queda y se ha militarizado el
país a raíz de la pandemia del hobbit 19
uno de estos casos es la desaparición de
cuatro líderes garífuna quienes fueron
secuestrados la mañana del 18 de julio
en la comunidad del triunfo de la cruz
según testigos por hombres fuertemente
armados y vestidos de militares hasta el
momento se desconoce el paradero de
todos estos desaparecidos de acuerdo a
berta oliva la preocupación de los
defensores de derechos humanos es
latente y temen retornar a una época
oscura donde se dieron desapariciones de
centenares de hondureños hablamos
específicamente de los 80 de estas
desapariciones el estado únicamente se
hizo responsables de 184
[Música]